this morning for our series the dish
we're learning about a very special
strawberry native to the foothills of
the japanese alps in winter the fruit is
celebrated for its taste and texture and
it's now being grown indoors near new
york city it's part of one company's
push to revolutionize the way our
produce is grown national correspondent
erica duncan visited the world's largest
indoor vertical strawberry farm where
she got to taste the very expensive
berry jerika good morning good morning
to you dana when hiroki koga first
tasted american strawberries they
weren't nearly as tasty as the ones he
remembered back home in japan in fact he
says they tasted like kiwi or cucumber
well now he's the ceo of oishi a company
defined the impossible by growing
strawberries vertically year-round it's
a challenging feat especially for this
kind of strawberry which actually grows
during the winter oishi is the first
step in his effort to improve quality
and sustainability in vertical farming
in a country whose produce industry
values transportation and mass
production koga's goal to make oishi the
world's biggest produce brand
ruby red fragrant and full of flavor
these omakase strawberries grown
naturally in the foothills of the
japanese alps are unlike any others in
the world
but thanks to a company now blending
technology with indoor farming our
journey to find the berries ended at a
warehouse in kearney new jersey the key
to producing these strawberries was how
well we can recreate that same
environment here in new jersey
hiroki koga is the ceo of oishi the
japanese word for tasty before coming to
the u.s koga worked as an indoor
vertical farming consultant in japan
where he's from
but here on his farm he's mastered the
art of growing berries like the ones
back home by controlling the environment
even in the japanese alps
the climate conditions change every day
as for here we can control every aspect
of the climate we know exactly when to
give water to these strawberries or when
to change temperatures so that they're
in the coziest environment
koga says he also successfully
engineered another critical element in
his farm
bees to pollinate the crop bees aren't
used to necessarily flying above and
working in that type of environment but
you found a way to make it work the key
is to really take the stress off of them
because when they're stressed they don't
know where to go how to fly they don't
know how to find flowers i feel like i'm
going to space they asked me what size i
wanted i said it's medium fashionable
achieving that rare bite of perfection
without chemicals requires painstaking
diligence
i suited up and took an air shower
before entering the farm julie noyce
manages the operation here how long are
you generally on this floor i always say
the strawberries don't sleep neither do
we the harvest has to happen every day
because there's a perfect ripeness when
did you know you have the perfect
strawberry the sweetness level is just
not comparable to anything that's
available we wanted to validate
that you know other people can also
taste the difference so what we did was
we knocked on doors of a michelin star
restaurants in manhattan as soon as you
open the package it's like this
explosion of
aroma in your face
neil hardin is executive chef at abcv in
new york he says the berry's quality and
uniqueness were a perfect match for his
plant-based menu they have like a really
delicate sort of velvety texture
and they basically just melt in your
mouth we use them kind of like we would
any
extra
special ingredient an eight pack of
berries cost fifty dollars that's at
least ten times more than the average
pack and there's a waiting list to
purchase them as a result it's been
dubbed the tesla of strawberries do you
agree with that description i think it's
a great analogy we're not just a
sustainable agriculture company but a
company that actually provides something
that is better way more expensive than
the average strawberries we did start
with these strawberries that are
expensive but this is a truly
differentiated experience and so we are
already working on our next generation
cultivars that we can produce for
for cheaper cost but would it taste the
same
yes
for koga strawberries are the beginning
of a produce revolution he's raised more
than 50 million dollars in investment
funds with plans to open new farms in
more cities the next crop
is going to be tomatoes but are they as
good as they look it is good
it's very good
it's sweeter
we could not like candy do this story
and not bring you these lovely
strawberries
explain again why do you have to wear
that get up just to go in with the
strawberries we have to wear the get up
to make sure the environment stays the
way i mean they're very particular about
the temperature the lighting um we
couldn't even get certain video because
it's it's serious it's a serious
operation what he's been able to do
um so it makes sure that we're not
contaminating the it's not just a matter
of washing your hands no i mean even the
fact that we had to suit up and go
through all of that at six dollars a
berry a little more right yeah i would
assume that that's what you're gonna
have this would be the fanciest thing
i've ever done i'm gonna eat a single
berry that cost six dollars off of a
porcelain tray look at how big you know
what javika this is really weird you
said right it is sweeter much sweeter it
has like a creamier texture i was just
going to say it's much creamier and
what's great about this is it's
consistent because how many times have
we gotten the berries and like three are
really good yes two are bad right it's
just that or that's the only thing that
price right
got to bring that down how do you get
them just online open orders are
good yeah um
but i have a feeling that they might be
you know more readily available in the
near future
will the price go down well he said
they're working on almost like another
model so not a tesla but the toyota
version perhaps no knock on toyota
he said it's gonna taste the same so are
those are those them two ones are those
the same can you scoot those
i'm not kidding they're really they're
really good they are
yeah they really are very good all right
thank you very much